monsieur whitman à bienvenu merci d'être
en direct avec nous alors la cgt a
publié un communiqué hier dans lequel
vous demander la réouverture immédiate
des urgences qu'en est il bonjour tout
d'abord envoyé des malades par tgv
soulage les services de rien mais cela
stature les autres régions qui auront
besoin de lits demain l'idri à bloquer
pour 20 jours en moyenne
mobilisé 150 550 personnel pour convoyer
prise de risque pour les malades plus
est un monument de leurs familles alors
que nous avons d'autres solutions intra
bureau à paris l'hôtel dieu
le val-de-grâce solution ouvrables
immédiatement avec les urgences de
l'hôtel-dieu fermés il y a dix jours le
scanner est un examen capitale il y as
disponibles 70 à 100 lits ouvrables tout
de suite et il l'est par elogic plus
simple moins deux d'amener le matériel
et le personnel plutôt que transbahuter
les malades
autre aberration les tempes à orly alors
qu'on a de vraies hôpitaux en dur alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire monsieur
whitman que l'état le gouvernement a mal
anticipé cette crise est en tout cas en
ce moment donné mauvaise réponse
effectivement le gouvernement en
participation l'avait acheté n'a pas d'à
part anticipé les moyens que que nous
avons nous actuellement dans nos
structures comme à l'hôtel dieu et le
val de grâce là actuellement les
urgences de l'hôtel dieu serait en
capacité d'être rouverte
oui et c'est le gouvernement qui ne veut
pas et la grèce les agences régionales
de la santé qui ne veut pas si tu il
tente pas de décision en fait pour le
faire en fait est fait dans mon pourquoi
ces politiques
ces politiques alors que comme je joue
comme je voulais je voulais dire on a un
scanner on avait des riads an auparavant
on a les moyens pour pour accueillir des
baladins du coc vide sans aucun problème
est là actuellement quelle est la
situation sur place à l'hôpital hôtel
dieu de paris et à les urbains
ça c'est triste parce que du coup on a
beaucoup de deux passions qui qui qui
qui arrive sur le thème dieu qu'ils
pensent être prise en charge pour par
rapport à octobre id est malheureusement
peut pas les accueillir ils doivent se
diriger sur d'autres hôpitaux et du coup
ça génère des tensions en fait au sein
de l'hôpital en fait parce que nous on
aimerait pouvoir les accueillir
et puis à les guider pour pour les
prendre en charge
damien whitman je répète que vous êtes
secrétaire général cgt de l'hôtel dieu à
paris vous étiez en direct sur rt france
merci